hello freak [ __ ] I feel like we're in
a very different space now with with the
consequences of misinformation we
certainly are do you think that they're
connected to what we're talking about
before we said that people would rather
be electrocuted than to be alone with
their thoughts that we have gotten to
this weird place with our society with
our civilization where we've made things
so easy we made people so soft so
dependent upon technology we've slotted
out these paths these predetermined
patterns of behavior to people for
people to follow where they can just
sort of plug into a philosophy whether
it's a right-wing one or a left-wing one
with very little room for personal
thought at all very very little room for
objective reasoning we sort of made it
easy we babied them I do think that it's
imperative if you want to be a good
citizen to have a very media diet you're
not gonna have a clear view of the world
if all you're reading it well either
more than your time right you know I
think you have nothing against the New
York Times or Breitbart but I think you
need to read many things and follow many
different sorts of people on Twitter not
just because you want to troll them but
because you actually want to listen to
what they have to say and take it
seriously well the New York Times really
[ __ ] up well they really [ __ ] up is
where they said that they're going to
after the election there they're going
to rededicate themselves to reporting
the truth and read like what why did you
say that like I wish I was there I wish
I was the office says they're biased
yeah
they [ __ ] up I mean as they were by I
mean right the the enemy is is was so
grotesque in this case that it was
impossible to not have been biased
seemed an abdication of responsibility
and I feel it myself like people
everything I say against Trump from a
Trump person sounds like mere partisan
bias
I mean I've got zero connection to the
Democratic Party or two I mean it's like
there's there's no partisan bias and
then everything this a hundred percent
of what I want to say about Trump does
not apply to
some other Republican who is just a
stands for things that I don't you know
policies I might not like it's
completely a completely unique
circumstance and yeah so it means yes
it's true that you want to read the New
York Times for the longest time it was
it was reading like just the entire
thing had become the opinion page on the
the Huffington Post or anything yeah I
just feel like at this stage of our our
society there's real consequences to the
infantile ization if that's actually a
word of human beings in our culture
we've made it very easy to just go to
work and just get home and watch
television and just not pay attention to
anything and not read anything and not
really think and and then be manipulated
I mean I think it's it's it's incredibly
easy manipulate people especially people
that are aware that they don't have a
varied media diet people that are aware
that they don't have a real sense of the
word and it seems daunting to try to
take into consideration like what is it
what is involved in foreign policy what
is involved in dealing with Russia what
is involved how do you negotiate with
North Korea [ __ ] it's too much put it in
the hands of the strongman I think this
is true on both sides of the spectrum
though because I think we've got folks
who slot into just a media diet where
they're just hearing things on the left
and they're not they're not curious
about or I guess just not curious but
enough to hear things from a different
perspective unless it's just some
right-wing palooka who comes on they
beat them up so I really do think I
think it places an incan this is gonna
be a self-serving argument but I do
think it places increasing importance on
media outlets like the one for which I
work to be really vigilant about being
seen as fair arbiters of fact yeah I
mean think the consequences have never
been greater for that absolutely the the
reason that so many people on the right
so many Trump supporters fear feel like
they're right is because it has been
proven that the the media was biased and
that they did get it all wrong and they
were
absolutely wrong when it came to who was
gonna win I mean Huffington Post had
some ridiculous thing where it was the
night of the election they said that
Hillary had like a 98 percent chance of
winning or something crazy like that
well I think yeah there were some polls
that were bad but the the poll like that
cuz I remember this because I sent out a
tweet which said like you know bye-bye
Donald or something like you know but
the day of but when I did that I mean
that wasn't a prediction in the the
polls that I was going by that most
people were going by at that point it
was it was like 8020 you know or at best
75 25 that she was going to win now
that's not I mean we rolled dice for a
few minutes you realize 20 percent
chance a lot that's right so I guess
that's not infinitesimal odds plus
Florida yeah but so but well you should
you should tell the story about what it
was like the anchor at the broadcast
yeah so I was anchoring that ABC News
digital coverage that night and you know
we they they give you the exit polling
who you're not supposed to report it
publicly but the exit polling that we
were seeing before we went on the air
letting the day really made it seem like
we're gonna be Clinton landslide you
know you have all these folks who say
look at the crestfallen faces of the
journalists because they're so upset
that Trump won certainly that was not
the case for the folks on are my said it
was that it was that we didn't see it
coming weren't prepare for it everything
that we were seeing in terms of the math
made it look like this was a Clinton
victory a shoo-in it was just about just
tying a ribbon around it so when the
night became long there was just
confusion about what was going on how
did they get it so wrong you know it's I
I think it actually goes back to what
Sam was saying before that people think
when you see numbers like 70 percent
that Clinton is gonna win 80 percent
odds that Clinton's gonna win that that
she's definitely gonna win but there's
room there for Trump yeah a lot of room
when a present comes up all the time
it's Russian roulette yeah yeah I miss
it bills are bad I've it's Russian
roulette those are bad odds right you're
not going to take that put single bullet
in it yeah no that's your hunter yeah
that's really good odds
so it's night
I don't think so it's just so much about
blaming the poles as it was blaming the
overall tenor of the coverage which made
it seem like Clinton wasn't evident yeah
yeah I just it was it was so shocking
that's a hit that's a hit I think that
we we can and should take yeah we
definitely you know I think we we
weren't giving the 20 or 30 percent
chance a serious enough look
[Applause]
[Music]